and my son who was 10 at the time  was sat on the stairs and he said are  you working today and I said I am and he  said I thought  but it's Sunday and I said I know buddy  but this the schedule's just so all over  the place you just got to get it done  it's only have a tiny amount of time  before we have to go back and do the  show  and uh  his face just kind of drops  and I got in the car  and uh I called my wife Jules and I said  I've realized best case scenario best  case scenario  we have  six more Summers  where Max is like  even remotely wants to be around us  and I cannot waste another one  so really the choice was to go well if I  want to do this other work that cannot  be at the expense of  our children our family